that how you greet folk in this world
deep and rewarding mechanics are the
heart of every good fighting game and
Soul Calibur SiC certainly has that but
for this series Adventure has always
been the soul that spirit of adventure
is most evident in Soul Calibur six is
two story modes libre of souls is the
meteor of the two and takes inspiration
from Soul Calibur 2's beloved weapon
master mode it's part fighting game part
role-playing game part Dungeons &
Dragons campaign you create your own
unique fighter embark on a journey that
will take you across the world and along
the way you'll cross paths and swords
with both named characters and
generically named bit Potter's libre of
souls tells its story primarily through
text but it's all surprisingly engaging
with dialogue and descriptions setting
the stage for the inevitable fire and
even giving its throw away opponents a
bit of flavor although you're ushered
between main quest missions various side
missions pop up around you with NPCs
asking for our hand solving their
problems the game does a valiant job of
role building along the way to giving
texture to its fantasy universe
completely side missions rewards you
with experience that levels you up and
this is where the RPG hooks are at the
strongest as you grow you'll be able to
use stronger weapons that have different
visual styles and properties enemies
also become harder and on top of that
special battle conditions spice up
fights these may make one type of attack
more effective while decreasing the
strength of another thus forcing you to
diversify your skill set within the
battle system
[Music]
food can be taken into battle to bestow
bonuses such as increased counter damage
a boost to health at the start of every
new round or extra experience for a win
to name a few you can also visit the
mercenary gills and hire a fighter
outfit them with weapons and food and
then send them into battle to do your
dirty work at best the AI will secure a
victory our worst they'll knock off some
health from the enemy before you step in
Libra of souls also has decision-making
moments some of which will simply
dictate how you act towards your
character while others will weigh your
soul towards good or evil impact the
story and decide how the ending battle
plays out the eventual consequence of
your actions is small but it's a neat
way to give you a tiny bit of authorship
in the story the main issue of Libra
Souls is the ratio of storytelling to
actual gameplay the mode is very text
heavy which would be less of a problem
if it's battles weren't so quick in the
hands of a capable fighting game player
many enemies can be dispatched within as
little as 10 seconds which means time
spent in Libra salt is heavily skewed
towards reading over fine and although
the loading screens before and after
battles are quite short they can become
increasingly tedious the mode is also
lacking in variety so beyond the
occasional battle condition it does very
little to keep you on your toes for the
most part applying an aggressive
strategy will see you emerge victorious
it's by guitarists the second mode soul
chronicles features a main story that
follows what happens with the legendary
soul edge but supplements this with 19
character specific campaigns each
drilling down and what the main cost are
doing while the broader story takes
place although they're heavily reliant
on static artwork they're fully voiced
and the artwork itself has an
eye-catching sketch like style
unfortunately there's a microcosm of
libra of salsas issues here too as
battles can be over within the blink of
an eye and that means more hitting
buttons to advance text now the less
both Libra of souls and soul Chronicle
make for a satisfying single-player
offering with the former lasting upwards
of eight hours and the latter taking
around four or five both give you plenty
to do and provide you with a
comprehensive engrossing story
throughout by the time they're over
you'll have travelled the world met a
variety of colorful characters and for
all manner of strange beasts quite the
adventure
the beauty of soul calibers gameplay is
in its simplicity and in that respect
Soul Calibur 6 is a bit like
rock-paper-scissors its most superficial
the rules of engagement are simple and
the pace of battle means decision making
is based on instinct as much as
considered tactics and being reactive
Soul Calibur 6 doesn't demand hours of
study and experimentation you can pick
up a controller and feel like you're
competent in no time although there are
complicated systems and techniques to
consider an inability to interact with
them doesn't loom over you before long
vertical attacks will reveal themselves
as powerful but slow you'll quickly
realize that horizontal attacks
interrupts sidesteps and our safe way to
apply pressure and kicks are a nice
balance between the two but have limited
range it takes a little time to
internalize these fundamentals and so
their intricacies become apparent much
quicker than in most fighting games
throw in blocking and movement both of
which are intuitive and the pickup and
play factor becomes a key strength of
Soul Calibur 6 there are more complex
systems beneath this simplicity though
so caliber six layers systems from
across the series on top of each other
so even veterans will need to examine
the individual pieces and figure out how
they all fit together the 8 way run
movement lets you modify attacks these
land at different heights high medium
and low which in turn makes blocking
become a three-tiered system more
confident players can react to an attack
by executing a law second guard impact
to repel and leave their opponent open
but a staggered player can retaliate
with a reversal impact which is
effectively a reversal reversal
from there it only gets more complicated
reversal edge is a special stance that
will counter incoming attacks at any
height it's executed with a single
button and the longer it's held the more
attacks it can absorb this makes
defending against an onslaught of
attacks really easy but the ease of
execution means it also steps on the
toes of the more skilled guard impact
reversal edge seems to be aimed at
casual players as while a successful god
impact places the initiator a more
advantageous position reversal edge
establishes a neutral playing field by
initiating a clash in this to fight is
effectively bet on what the other player
will do and counter it this is a useful
way to create some breathing room when
being smothered but the guessing game
leads to a feeling of randomness that
can be frustrating
the workaround here is to simply land an
unblockable break attack to stop the
reversal edge beyond that there are
critical edges which are the game's the
equivalent of a super move these are
governed by the soul gauge which is
built up by attacking defending and
taking damage it can be spent on
executing this incredibly powerful and
outlandish cinematic attack
a soul gauge can also be spent on a soul
charge a comeback state of sorts that
opens up a separate set of moves for a
character to use it also powers up
normal attacks and makes them cause
damage to blocking opponents for a brief
period those are just a few of the
systems in Soul Calibur 6 so for those
that want to become students of the game
it offers plenty to learn however at
times it can also feel needlessly
complex this is likely a symptom of
creating a collection of systems that
give hardcore fighting game players that
depth they crave while also enabling
casual players to stand their ground
against them the end result is a
construction that is ads with itself
with the simpler parts undermining the
complex ones and although it works its
inelegant from a network perspective
Soul Calibur 6 is online modes felt
stable and consistent we played a number
of matches in rank and had no trouble
finding other players connecting and
having smooth fights
it offers ranked and casual modes and a
replay mode where you can save your own
fights or favor of battles members of
the community at large are having to
watch later overall Soul Calibur 6 is
online sui is fairly no-frills sticking
to the basics but doing them well Soul
Calibur 6 is a fighting game that's easy
to recommend like all the best titles in
the genre it has a low barrier to entry
and a high skill ceiling for those
looking to get in a few games with
friends it's welcoming and immediately
enjoyable but for those committed to
plowing the depth of its systems to get
tournament ready it has plenty to unpack
and understand better still anyone who
wants to play along will find Soul
Calibur 6 has some of the most
substantial single-player content in any
fighting game today
[Music]